Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to use this new AI film
director technique to reimagine videos and
even movies just by saying what we want to
add to it.
Yes, really!
And you will see that the results are absolute
insanity.
Now, previous techniques are already able
to take a photo of someone, add a beard, make
them young or old, but this work, this is
something else.
Why?
Well, this can do the same for not only one
still image, but for an entire video.
Just imagine how cool it would be to create
a more smiling version of an actor without
actually having to re-record the scene.
Hold on to your papers, and look at how we
can take the original video of an Obama speech,
and make it a little happier by adding a smile
to his face.
Or even make him younger, or older.
These are absolutely amazing.
I love the grey hair, I love the young man
hair, I love how the gestures and head turns
are going through.
This looks like something straight out of
a science fiction movie.
Loving it.
Now, what is the key here?
The key here is that this AI knows about temporal
coherence.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that it does this in a way
when it synthesizes the second image, it remembers
what it did to the first image, and takes
it into consideration.
That is not trivial at all.
And if you feel that this does not sound like
a huge deal, let’s have a look at an earlier
technique that doesn’t remember what it
did a moment ago.
Prepare your eyes for a fair bit of flickering.
This is an AI-based technique from about 6
years ago that performs style transfer.
And when creating image 2, it completely disregards
what it did in image 1.
As you see, this really isn't the way to go.
And, with all this newfound knowledge, let’s
look at the new footage of the new AI and
look at the temporal coherence together.
Just look at that.
That is absolutely incredible.
I am seeing close to perfect temporal coherence.
My goodness.
Now, not even this technique is perfect.
Look, when trying it here, Mark Zuckerberg’s
hair seems to come to a life of its own.
I also find the mouth movements a bit weaker
than with the other results.
Now, if you allow me, let me also enter the
fray.
Well, this is not me, but how the AI reimagines
me as a young man.
Good job little man, keep those papers coming!
This is incredible, I love it.
And this is what I actually look like.
Okay, just kidding.
This is old man Károly as imagined by the
AI, who is vigorously telling you that papers
were way better back in his day.
This is the original.
And this is my sister, Karolina filling in
when I am busy.
I would say that the temporal coherence is
weaker here, but it is understandable because
the AI has to do a ton of heavy lifting by
synthesizing so much more than just a smile.
And even with all these amazing results, so
far you have seen nothing yet.
No sir.
It can do even more.
If you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper, because it
works not only on real humans, but, animated
characters too.
And just look at that.
We can order these characters to smile more,
be angrier, or happier.
And we can even add lipstick to a virtual
character, without having to ask any of the
animators and modelers of this movie.
How cool is that?
And remember, we were lucky to be able to
do this to one still image just a couple papers
ago.
And now, all this, with temporal coherence.
And, I hope you are enjoying these results,
many of which you can only see here on Two
Minute Papers.
Nowhere else.
And, of course, I would like to send a huge
thank you to the authors who took time off
their busy day to generate these just for
us.
Now, even the animated movie synthesis has
some weaker results, in my opinion, this is
one of them, but still, very impressive.
And don’t even get me started about the
rest, these are so good!
And just imagine what we will be able to do
just a couple more papers down the line.
My goodness.
What a time to be alive!
So, what would you use this for?
What do you expect to happen a couple more
papers down the line?
Please let me know in the comments below.
I’d love to hear your thoughts.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!